The ninth installment of the "The Fast and the
Furious" franchise is racing toward the finish
line and onto the big screen. The latest movie in
the high-octane series was released in Hong Kong,
South Korea, and Russia in May 2021, and soon the
rest of the world will be able to join in on the
gasoline-scented action and thrills of "F9." The
film broke records at the box office, debuting
at $163 million in its international opening, and
with earnings now over $6 billion worldwide. With
those numbers, it doesn't look like the movie
will be stepping on the brakes anytime soon.
The "Fast and Furious" movies have
been on track for 20 years now,
and the newest film promises more wild stunts
and heart-pounding chases than ever before.
"F9" sees the return of director Justin
Lin, who previously helmed the "Fast
and Furious" films 3 through 6. Here's
everything we know about the film so far.
The "F9" movie has been in limbo for nearly two
years, with various delays causing the film to
be pushed back several times. The initial plan
would have seen "F9" in theaters back in the
summer of 2019, but that release date was put on
hold to make room for the release of the buddy
comedy spin-off, "Hobbs and Shaw." Universal, the
film's distributor, then made plans for a May 2020
release, but had to push things back once again
because of the pandemic. At last, the wait for
American audiences will soon be over, as "F9"
finally releases State-side on June 25, 2021.
Now that the U.S. has seen a surge of
vaccinations to fight off the coronavirus,
film studios are optimistic that more audiences
will be flocking to theaters this summer.
With many public places reopening and lifting
many of their restrictions, Universal is hoping
that "F9" will be as big of a box office
smash in the States as it has been overseas.
"Fast and Furious" fans are no doubt eager to
see the return of their favorite characters
in the long-awaited sequel, and they will not
be disappointed. Franchise veteran Vin Diesel
leads the cast of "F9," reprising his role as
protagonist Dominic Toretto. Dominic has come
a long way from the first film in the series
— from leading his own gang of criminals,
to becoming a fugitive on the run, to graduating
to a kind of high-profile, gray-market mercenary
tasked with taking down some of the most
dangerous crime lords around the world.
"You got
the best crew in the world
standing right in front of you.
Give 'em a reason to stay."
Michelle Rodriguez returns as Letty Ortiz,
the tough-as-nails mechanic and the love of
Dominic's life. Letty and Dom have been through a
lot together over the years, from Letty's supposed
death to her amnesia, and the ultimate return of
her memories. If their history is anything to go
by, it's unlikely that the couple will have
much time to themselves in the newest film.
Also returning for "F9" are Tyrese Gibson as Roman
Pearce, Chris "Ludacris" Bridges as Tej Parker,
Jordana Brewster as Mia Toretto, and
Lucas Black as Tokyo Drift's Sean
Boswell. A notable addition to the cast is, of
course, John Cena, who will play Jakob Toretto,
Dom's long-lost brother, who has become a
master thief and assassin. Charlize Theron
will return as cyberterrorist Cipher, teaming
up as the co-antagonist alongside Cena's Jakob.
The official summary for "F9" promises
multiple settings in "F9," and has the
crew trotting around the globe in the newest film.
London, Tokyo, and Edinburgh are just
a few of the locations mentioned,
along with Central America and the scenic capital
of Tbilisi, Georgia. The summary also reads:
"Along the way, old friends will be resurrected,
old foes will return, history will be rewritten,
and the true meaning of family
will be tested like never before."
Also of note: The "Furious" crew will
finally be heading into outer space,
because of course they will.
Long time "Fast and Furious" fans
know how much family means to Dom.
"I don't got friends. I got family."
Although we don't know much
about Jakob at this point,
there is certain to be plenty of conflict
as Dom goes up against his long-lost
brother — and seeing him team up with one
of Dom's most dangerous foes from the past
is sure to pile on the drama. And, of
course, most importantly, Han is back:
"Nice clubhouse."
We can't wait to see how Dom and his crew take on
this newest set of challenges when
"F9" finally arrives in the U.S.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.